okay now as a sort of segue into this
right I want you to think about logs
first because we're a little more
comfortable with logs when you
differentiate log of everything and
chain rule what of a function of some
kind of wonderful okay we know what the
derivative is its f dashiell meth yes
okay so you guys are starting to get
better at recognizing this guy right and
integrating to end up here right so
you're starting to see things like or
things like this and you recognize you
like Oh F dash on earth so I'm going to
end up with a lot okay but I want you to
think with me what about what happens
with the inverse trig functions okay for
instance if i differentiate sine inverse
of a function what would change will
tell me okay well I'm going to get I
have to do the inside right so we'll get
f dash okay and then the rest of it is
one over so i'm just going to probably
crashing okay what's on the denominator
it's very
1 minus a function square ok now this is
hard this is very hard these are quite
easy to recognize after some time right
but when you square and then you do this
subtraction right it's hard to see where
where's the eff that results in this f
dash because it's been much around with
quite a bit ok so what will happen is
you'll get very simple examples ok or
they'll provide you the substitution ok
and they'll say use this substitution to
integrate this now I'm going to show you
both ok so here's my first example where
the writer yeah okay well before I do
that we should do the UM we should do
the chain rule for tan inverse ok so
it's going to be almost identical right
except we're going to lose the square
root and we'll lose the minus sign ok so
easy example to stop it let's go
integrate X on 1 plus X to the 4 that's
why i said good now you look at this and
if we did a noite inverse trig we would
say hmm ok well it doesn't match f dash
on earth does it I mean you sort of
scratch it don't you but we sort of
recognize it's going to fit under one of
these there's no square root so it's
probably not going to be sine inverse it
quite comfortably fits under this tan
inverse kind of idea right so to make
sure we don't screw it up I'm going to
do the full substitution ok I'm going to
say let u equal now if you feel
comfortable doing in your head that's
great it'll be quicker ok but I think
your likelihood of mixing up my
constants or getting your derivative of
your f wrong I think it's a senior is to
take so I don't do it what should I
choose I'll go 1 plus X to the 4 on the
denominator right so what would be an
appropriate choice for F looks likely to
be x squared right if I stick it x
squared there I'll get 1 plus x squared
squared that's what I want right so i'll
let u equal
okay that gives me a result for the
derivative do you okay and now I've got
all my pieces don't know okay I've got a
single XD X here X the X I kind of want
two of them right so therefore what I've
got is actually half the size of what
I'm after right then i've got i've
replaced that XD X with a d you okay and
I chose you specifically so that I would
have 1 plus u squared they're perfect
okay so this is a half tan inverse of
you plus my constant and then you just
get rid of good use again okay good now
that was a fairly easy example so they
won't provide you a I'm a substitution
to use on that because I think you can
see it there right let me give you
another one but it's a bit trickier I
think it's about the limit of what they
would expect you to recognize without
providing you a substitution so have a
try win this one
stare at it with me for a little while
now part of the problem is like we're
expecting an f dash on the top and some
kind of something squared on the volume
aren't we and that gives us two problems
because number one you know you really
hope we don't have much of a function on
the top and down here I don't have
anything squared or do I that square
roots a bit of a signal to you isn't it
right where might that square root come
in I need to have something squared in
order to use this result don't I okay
hmm would you like some time to think
about yourself before I spoil it no just
blow me my brave for this time of day my
brain hurts okay all right here's what
I'm going to do i need something on the
numerator write something on the new
mayor to match this so i had a choice i
can put either of these on the numerator
minus the fraction all right which would
be more likely as a candidate which ones
more likely to be f dash and which one
is more likely to be f squared where you
can just think in terms of degree can't
you ok this is degree hi this is degree
one so I think the one with the lesser
degree is likely to be up the top so i'm
going to write it as 1 over 2 root days
ok now it's on the numerator as a
fraction are you okay with that now I
need something squared on the bottom
something squared well i have x there x
is the square root of x squared is it
not I need something squared so that
looks like the best option this looks
like it'll work for me does this fit if
this is f is this f dash and the answer
is yes because this is extra half right
if we were to differentiate you would
get a half x to the power of negative a
half that works ok hard to see though
isn't it ok it's much harder than with
just logs but now I'm in the right
position there is my F dash there's my F
I can actually just go straight to the
next line
that's tan inverse of F plus my constant
okay of course if you're struggling to
see that a little more and go in there
directly you can do the substitution you
can say let u equal the square root of x
so therefore do you on d x equals 1 on 2
root x and then go from there okay but
you can see it now